deflation is something that doesn't
happen often
everything gets cheaper coffee shoes
bicycles this makes consumers happy but
there's a dark side in the long run it's
bad for the economy because it means
deflation
with deflation prices fall and you get
more for your money but the money supply
also decreases that's exactly the
opposite of its counterpart inflation
here prices increase at the same high
rate as the money supply in deflation
products food and houses lose value
continuously but no one can afford to
buy them anymore because they don't have
enough money how does this happen
consumers here there's a crisis become
worried and buy less companies can't
sell their products so they're forced to
lower their prices but they can no
longer cover their production costs they
must cut wages and lay off employees in
the end only a few people have money and
they're reluctant to spend it because
they're waiting for prices to fall even
further
the result is a deflationary spiral that
drags everything into the abyss and what
can be done to prevent this from
happening central banks can cut their
interest rates they hope this will bring
more money into circulation and
encourage borrowing and stop deflation
in its tracks